[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته نرحب
بعشاق الابتكار عبر شاشه الام بي سي 4 منذ
الموسم الاول وحتى هذه اللحظه تلقى نجوم
العلوم اكثر من اربعين الف طلب مشاركه
القليلون منهم يصلون الى هذه المرحله بعد
جولات من الغربله والتدقيق فالموسم الثامن
يتسع فقط لتسعه ابتكارات اليوم عشرات
المشتركين المحظوظين حملوا احلامهم واتوا
بها من مرحله الاختيار الاوليه الى المجلس
العلمي وهاهم يقفون على ابوابه املينا ان
تصبح احلامهم حقيقه على ايدي خمسه حكام
متخصصين بمجالات الحوسبه والتكنولوجيا
المعلومات الطاقه والبيئه الصحه وعلوم
الطب الحيوي ورياده الاعمال طبعا لانه طين
الانتظار نفتتح سويا ابواب المجلس العلمي
النتيجه خلصت يعني اقامتك بالدوحه خلصت
سجلت حلقات التصفيات الكثير من المواجهات
العلميه واللحظات الصعبه انا شخصيا ما اقت
انت دي فكرتك وبتقول ان ده ابتكار اعمل
عليه
معلش
والله بجد
اذا كان الهدف اختراع شلتي فهذا ليس
باختار
صغيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وتسعه عشر مشتركا نجحوا في اجتياز المرحله
الاولى
اليوم موعد المواجهه الحسم
لجنه التحكيم في وجه المشتركين
[موسيقى]
انه المجلس العلمي
والى مكان انعقاده في المقر الرئيسي
لمؤسسه قطر بدا توافد الحكام
والله هو اليوم نهار نهار كريتيكول
الدجاجز وللمشاركين ايضا على طاولته تسعه
عشر مشروعا وخارج اسواره تسعه عشر مشتركا
ينتظرون الحكم
مسؤوليه كبيره لان في وايد افكار حلوه
ولازم احدد افضل الافكار
انا متحيز لمشاريع تكون هندسيه تكون
مشاريع فيها تطبيق فيها شغل هذه المره
للجنه صلاحيات
موسقه فقد تستد
عي في ايه لحظه من دون علم وتم استر
للمجلس العلمي
مهم جدا انه يكون المتابع حاضر لانه اكثر
واحد ممكن يدافع عن الاختراع بتاعه وكتير
جدا بتقف في الاخر على سؤال
هذا السؤال
بيسوى مليون لانه بناء على جوابك رح تفوت
على المختبر ولا لا في ختام المجلس تسعه
افكار ستكتب لها انطلاقه علميه جديد عبر
نجوم العلوم
هذا هو اليوم اللي بدنا ندمج كل مخرجات
هالاختصاصات ونشوف شو في عنا من النهايه
للتسعه اليوم لو في بالورشه العمل محل
تسعه عشر مشارك كنا اخذناهم كلهم لانه
كلهم تاهلوا ولكن للاسف في فقط محل لتسعه
اشخاص هلا العشره الباقيه يمكن دكتور احمد
بيستقبله عندهم بالمركز مرحبا مرحبا
غسان يوسف يا دكتور احمد انت كنت متحمس يا
فزعك
واعطيته ضوء اخضر او انت مقدما فيه اجا
اللاعب مثلا اعتبر دكتور احمد
يحاول انه يقتل يقتنص مني نقطه اوكي
بعض اللاعبين بيشعروا ان مفيش فيرنس في
التحكيم
لهذا السبب في بدله يلبسها لاعب
التايكواندو كلها تحسب الضربات وشده
الضربات غسان على سبيل المثال هو لاعب
تايكوندو ويشعر انه انظلم يعني
بحس انه انت بهالموضوع عندك تجربه شخصيه
انت مظلوم
ظلموه كانت في الاختيارات
حضرتك فيها هيك يعني
[موسيقى]
هو جاب سيره الظلم في انه لا تستخدم كل
المعلومات في الرانكن وترتيب من اللاعبين
وانتقاء للفريق الوطني
وهو من الاشخاص اللي دفع ثمن بالترتيب
لانه اذا
حتى لايف للناس ليشوفوا منو هذا الشخص
للمشاهد ممكن البريزنتر ولا اللاعب انه
صار في عنده
بروفايل محترم وتراكت ومعترف فيه انا شفتك
متحمس لا متحمس
[موسيقى]
من سوريا
كانت مقدمه
عشان لما يفسد الفود
يتعرف يتغير اللون والباركود يتغير بحيث
انه تعرف ان فسد
عنده مشكله بهذا الشيء
بس هلا بالفايل بعثت كل شيء عندي وان شاء
الله خير ما بعرف بتخيل رح ينادوني نقطه
ضعف الوحيده في رايي يعني انها اي شيء
بس انا كتير
انا رحت معي اكياس الذكيه او بالبيت بجيب
البضاعه لحمه او خضره او دايره بدي احطها
بالبراد او بدي حطها مطرح حطها بها الكيس
والانديكيتر بخبرني اذا هذه الساعه صالحه
ولا بدي كبه وهون بدي استفهم انه اذا
حطينا فيها لحمه وطلعت صوره
ما بعرف اذا كنا استعملناها الكيس للديري
برودكت هل بطلع سمن
حتى الكاميكشن ما عرفتها هي جازز هي فلور
هي ما بعرف شو يعني عندك رياكشن شرحت لنا
شرحت قالت انه امونيا بتطلع وما شرحتش
وقلت لا قالت احنا احسن نجيبها نشوف
خليها تشرح لان
الموضوع هي الباجراون كمثري
طيب خليها تيجي
خليها تنجمع البيبي يعني
حاسه انه موجود عم يعطيني كتير
حافز بالنسبه الي
ما بعرف ان شاء الله خير
اهلا
فيكم
اذا كنت معتبري اللقاء السابق كنا ثلاثه
كان صعب هلا عززنا القوات وصرنا خمسه
اسئله لك واحد لا بس للحوم اثنين ايه
بالظبط الكومبوزيشن
قلت انا اول مره انه هو لكل انواع الاغذيه
بينما لكل صنف معين راح يكون انديكيتر خاص
مثلا للحوم راح يكون
فينولد بالنسبه للدواجن ممكن يكون
الميوبلوبين
او السيلفر من خبرتك كام هلا فيك تقولي
لنا شو عم يصير عند البيبي هون هل هي هذه
مضايقه فيزيائيه كيميائيه فيزيولوجيه شو
القصه هون ولا في رائحه
الحمد لله على السلامه يلا خلاص توضحنا
الفكره
وان الله راد
ان شاء الله بنشوف المرحله السابقه
المرحله القادمه
شكرا
[موسيقى]
بطلت تبكي البنت لانه شافت في وهره
[ضحك]
راح يختاروا افضل تسعه ان شاء الله اكون
بيناتهم بس انا قدمت كل شيء عندي وجاوبت
على كل الاسئله في قلق وترقب وكله اي حد
بيخرج بنساله اهم حاجه رد فعل اللجنه
معصبه ولا ولا هاديه لانها يعني هينعكس
علينا احنا طبعا يعني احمد
يترقب قرارا اللجنه وهو بامسي حاجه الى من
ياخذه بالاحضان
ناخد عاصفه وكده
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
هم كافي
هو فكرته بلال تصنيع كابسيولز بتاع القهوه
فرنسي هو جزائري بيحكيك باللهجه الجزائريه
هو جزائري فرنسا اسهل
[ضحك]
يعني اضطريت انا ما بقدرة كم كلمه فرنسي
[موسيقى]
ا
يعني
قويه جدا في منهم البروفيسور وفي منهم
دكتور في منهم اللي ماخذ ماجستير وانا لسه
صغير يعني 21 سنه لكن قدها وقدود وان شاء
الله نتحداهم كلهم ونوصل المركز الاول
مثلا انا اذا واحد اخذ لي صوره هيك فلات
تودي في ناس بياخذ لي 3d ساعتها بيكتشف
انه منخاري كتير كبير مثلا
[ضحك]
سؤال مهم خلينا من الوجه هي لو في لو سكتش
بسيط يبقى العدد الخطوات اللي محتاجينها
يعني ممكن يتم لو سكتش معقد زي ما تقول
الوجه وفيتش وملامح هذه حتكون ممكن
ما تنعمل هيك انت دكتور احمد لخصته ولا
الموسم بنجوم العلوم الجائزه توصل جوائز
مليون دولار بقى السؤال المليون دولار هو
اللي انت سالته وانت راح نطلب منك تساله
راح نستدعي تنشوف اذا بيعملوا نمبر وان
بالاي سي تي وبنجوم العلوم او
بروح بقول هذا عم يحلم
الجوائز مجموعه مليون دولار ووقتها
نستدعيهم ليجاوبوا على سؤال واحد يعني هذا
السؤال بيسوى مليون لانه بناء على جوابك
بفوت على المختبر ولا لا لذلك جوابك على
السؤال بالمجلس العلمي فعلا هو سؤال
المليون دولار مرحبا بك عليه اهلا الدكتور
احمد لخص كل تساؤلاتنا بتوضيح كثير مهم
ركز كثير منيح وجابوا للدكتور احمد لانه
هيدي هي اللي بتفرق يا راح تكون هون
وعنترجم حلمك او رح ترجع تحلم عن جديد
الان علي البرامج الموجوده الان
فيها كتير اللي تعمل
تحويل من ثنائي الابعاد الى ثلاثي الابعاد
لا بس بطريقه يدويه مش اوتوماتيك يعني
يعني انا اجيب استعين بالصور عشان اسوي
المجسم لكن ما في شيء اوتوماتيك عندك صوره
انسان عادي
كيف تخرج منها 3d انا محتاج اذا انا محتاج
منك بس الجهه الاماميه والجهه اليمنى
النص هذا للنص الثاني تتكون الشخص لكن راح
اخذ منك الجهه الخلفيه والجهه الاماميه
واليمنى واليسرى
والتصميم نفسها في الاستعمال خبرتي
للبرنامج نفسه يعني انا مريت بهالشي حاولت
دور المبرمج ولا الرسام ولا الفنان ولا
رجل الاعمال ولا الفيلسوف شو راح تكون راح
يكون الرسام الرسام والمصمم المدير لهالشي
المدير والفيلسوف الفيلسوف
وضحت وضحك
[موسيقى]
الضغط النفسي في اوجه
الترقب سيد الموقف
والكل يعد الثواني
دقات قلبي تتسارع يعني انه ما في البني
ادم بيفوت على نوع من الامتحان وبيكون
100%
ممكن مستقبل كله يتغير خلال الاختراع واحد
فوق ان شاء الله فتحته
مستوى بس احس في استراس اكثر يعني اما
نكون من التسعه او اما لا كل ما هو قادم
فهو اصعب من الابل هؤلاء المشتركون بامس
الحاجه الى بصيص امل الى حبل نجاه يتمسكون
به
ها هم امينه الحواج محمد وطفه وماجد
اللبابيدي خرجون عاشوا تجربه نجوم العلوم
يعودون للمنافسه ليس كمشتركين هذه المره
بل كمرشدين الوصول لعتبه برنامج نجوم
العلوم محتاج انك تكون مبتكر ومخترع
وكفاءه عاليه اعتمادا على خبرتهم سيختار
كل منهم ثلاثه مشتركين للدعم والتوجيه حتى
الوصول الى نهائيات نجوم العلوم خبرت
الخمس سنين هي السبب من اسباب النجاح اللي
راح يكون ماشي مع المشتركين الجدد
بالسيزونيت اتذكر ايام ما كنا في نفس
المكان ونفس الوقت يعني فتره تكون
بالبرنامج طلعت الاول بكذا مرحله وما بقبل
الا الاول وهلا كمان التيم اللي بتشتغل
معي ما بقبل الا يكون اولا
عبد الرحيم
سمارت ميديا تيشيرت فورتشن
هم الاطفال عندهم المرض الاحاديه التوحد
التوحد الواحد
بيبقى عندهم مشكله انه
يعني تشوف هم وساعات بيكون في حاجات محتاج
تعملها لما يبدا مثلا هو يدخل بمود معين
في المرض محتاج تخرجه منه فهو اللي عمله
انه عمل تيشيرت وفيها
اولا بتشوف اذا كان الطفل بيتحرك
بتاع حركته وكل ده موجود لكن اللي هو
اضافه انه قال ان انا كمان
حدي
او الكير تيكرز يعملوا ايه
استنادا على النمط او الحركه التي يقوم
بها هو يرسل على الموبايل مثلا يقول يبدو
ان سمير حزين سمير لم يقم اليوم بنشاط من
فضلك شغل الاداه اسفل هو عنده خبره في في
ميدان السانسيوس
قوي قوي جدا يعني
[موسيقى]
ده هو
كلبت بتاعت ان انت بتاخد بتحط سامبل على
هو اللي عمله انه هو عمل اوتوماتيك وقال
انه بتوفر في الوقت وبتزود في هو ده انا
يعني بشوف انا ده هو معقم جدا ولو رجعنا
باقي يعني رجعنا بالذاكره كمان سنتين وكان
الاعتراض عليه انه مش هتلحق يا خيي تعمل
هذا البروتو تاعي انا
بعدين حكى معي دكتور مراد حكى
ما بتقدر تعمله في
كان حكي مضبوط اخد معي
عن جديد
وانا جاهز هون بدي منكم تساعدوني نفوت على
ملك
[موسيقى]
صديق مطلوب الى الحضور امام اللجنه في
مذكره استجلاب
انت بتشتغل فين دلوقتي بشتغل
فيها طيب
عشان انا عايز اخد الجائزه بتاعه
النجوم العلوم انا كنت يعني
انا حكيتها بالكاستنج نجوم العلوم مش بس
برنامج بروجرام
انا بدي هذا
من
امريكا كان حياخذ وقت قد ايه عشان يوافقوا
عليه
نجوم العلوم الثلاثه يراقبون المشتركين عن
كثب
يتواصلون معهم للاطلاع على مشاريعهم
والاختيار فرقهم محمسين لنشوف المشتركين
وهو هيك نتعامل مع بعض ان شاء الله نعمل
شي حلو كتير هلا الكنده يمكن اصعب مرحله
بالكل مراحل انا مرقت فيها هي
اكيد يعني
اصعب مرحله هي
واهم شيء يتقبلوا انه الثاني والثالث مش
لالا بس الاول ان شاء الله
شو الاول بس لي ما بهمني الاول ولا الثاني
ولا الثالث والرابع انا بهمني الشخص يعمل
كل شيء بيقدر عليه انا من الاشخاص اللي ما
طلعت من الفاينا الفور بس عملت كل شيء
بقدر عليه والحمد لله ايهاب ما يقوم انا
يعني اذا مش الاول عيني ليك
عم يطلع انا مين هو عنده هذا
انه بده يطلع الاول
ولا الثاني ولا الثالث نحن
[موسيقى]
نقص عليهم يعني
عارفه عادل يا بيضه محمد بيض يعني
المركز الاول
ويزعم طيب محمد نعرفك يعني ههه الاول
ماشي
التيم اللي راح اضيفه له لازم يكون امينه
لازم يكون عنيد وواثق من وين بيوصلها
ويكون قوي لما اقول قوي يعني يقدر يكسر
تيم محمد واطفه وتيم ماجد
عشان اكسر راس محمد
حيكون مو منافسه شريفه راح تكون مصارعه
شريفه
رح اخذ احسن ثلاثه ان شاء الله مع العلم
انه التسعه اكيد رح يكونوا منا بس احسن
ثلاثه رح اخذهم وراح نمشي معهم ان شاء
الله لاخر الطريق
في الداخل النقاش يحتدم فالحكام يعيدون
النظر في ادق الخوارزميات المسؤوليه كبيره
والمشاريع المختاره من شانها حل معضلاتي
عالمنا العربي في النهايه الابتكار
والابداع هو ما يميز بين القائدي والتابع
من هم القاده تسعى الموسم الثامن ومن
سيعود الى دياره الرؤيه ستتضح اكثر بعد
الفاصل الذي يمكنكم من خلاله مشاركتنا
تعليقاتكم الاوليه حول المجلس عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر وايضا على السناب شات
[موسيقى]
لو شعرتم بالطاقه في هذه القاعه اكتشفتم
انها قادره على توليد الكهرباء تضيء
الدوحه وضواحيها ماذا يقول مبتكر الكهرباء
العبقريه عباره عن 1% من الالهام
و99% من الجهد الجهد بدله هؤلاء المشتركين
اما الالهام فيعود للحكام لاختياري افضل
تسعه بينهم
احس المفروض يعني تحطون لنا سكرين ونشوف
الرياكشن عشان ما نتوتر يعني ما فينا نعرف
هلا هلا
من البحرين بتتذكر انا صورت له احمر
وتحدثكن انت والسيده عائشه انه انا رح
شارعكم
ضدكم بالمجلس العلمي
اعلان حرب ولا هو منو حرب بينما تحدي تحدي
اعلان تحدي يعني زملائي القطريين حابين
يستضيفونك هون على القليله للمرحله
الثانيه بالمجلس العلمي وهني راح يناقشوا
ملف بالمجلس العلمي
ويدافعوا عنه انا مش قادر يدافع عنه
بالمجلس العلمي انه هذا اختراع
عملت ازمه هلا بيني وبين زملائي بس رح
نحلها بالمجلس العلمي علميا ان شاء الله
دكتور فؤاد قلبي يدق والله والله
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
كل واحده من النقاط لوحدها ما فيهاش شيء
جديد تجميع النقط هذه كلها مع بعضها
والمانط بتاع البيشنت فيها نوع من النوع
من النوفلتي مش يعني
يعني
مو موجود بتاتا احنا بس مجرد قاعدين نلعب
قاعدين نلعب في الاجهزه نلعب في
التكنولوجي عشان اننا نسوي شيء جديد
استعمالات جديده والماركه تحتاجه يعني في
انه مجمع
ساوند سيستم حتى قلت لها سمال زيدي فيها
روائح كمان بس انه صارت بزنس يعني لازم
تروح على حضنه الاعمال تستثمر فيها يا
دكتور فؤادي موجوده ساره الان هي موجوده
موجوده
بدنا نشوف شو بدنا تخبركم انا مو متوتره
يعني ينادوني الناحين حق النقاش
احسان التكنيك بسم الله
اختراع عجيب وغريب
وانت ما هو دورك في الاختراع هذا
هجوم اقدر اصنعها في شهرين شهرين ونص
تقريبا
بدنا نرتاح نفسيا
في توترات مختلفه بس توتر موجود وارتاح
عن طريق يعني انه بس حق تامل تبي ترتاح
هلا الجهاز بصير
يعني اذا فيك شيء عن بدل يعني
عندك الطبيب
هو اللي حدد
لكنك
يلا ان شاء الله بنشوفك خارج ان شاء الله
مع السلامه شكرا ساره
اظن
ندخل ساره بس لنشوف فؤاد في الشمبر
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
لانه انا عندي مهارات
مش لانه انت امراه ولا انت رجل لا انت
بتقيم بتقيم الاول تقييم اكاديمي اكاديميه
ممتاز شو هو
ما اعرفش شكرا
[موسيقى]
اتفضل ريان هو شاب لبناني واخترع هذا
التيشيرت حط عليه انه يقول له كيف وضعه
على وحتى ورانا يعني الوضع الصح وايه
الوضع الغلط بتاع الباك وكده بيعطيه واتس
اي دي البوستر
بيخليه يزود تبعه طبعا
انا
تخيل طبعا
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
انا هلا محتار يا اما ملف كتير منيح ومشي
الحال يا اما مش منيح وما الي حق شارع حتى
يعني اذا ملفي مرق وشافوا كل المعلومات
كامله معناته ما في داعي يستدعوني بتمنى
انه هذا يكون هو الاحتمال
تقريبا هذه المره الثانيه اوصل الى المجلس
مرات
ففي خبره شويه يوم نجيب فرشاه اسنان يوم
نجيب مشط للشعر كل يوم يجينا بشغله ولكن
هو كان مصمم انه يضل يناقش لجنه الحكم
بنجوم لدرجه صار في علاقه شخصيه
[موسيقى]
يمكن يقدم السنه الجايه استعدوا يا
بتدخلوه يا بهددكم بمشاركه جديده
لكن يعني
بحكم اني متعود على النجوم العلوم توتر
اقل يمكن يكون من بقيه مشتركين
[ضحك]
الحفاظ على سلامه الاولاد وقت خروجهم من
المدرسه الان 500 متر قبل ما توصل للمدرسه
في الاب تعلم الاب انك انت 500 متر رقم
الطفل يطلع على الشاشه ان الطفل يطلع قدام
المدرسه وتستقبله انت وانت ماشي هذا عشان
يحد من الزحمه السيارات وقت الانصراف من
المدرسه اذا ما طلعت فوق معناته انه ما في
مشاكل هذا
يكون
فيه الاستخدام كفيديو
والثاني
للجيمنج ممكن انه احنا لما بدنا مثلا نعرض
عضو معين في جسم الانسان القلب شرايين
بمجرد ما يمسكها الدكتور اللي بده يعلم
الطلاب اللي عنده بحطها عندهم بفرجيهم كيف
القلب شو مكونات القلب شوي حامل بايديك
قلت له شو دخل اليوتيوب هذا الكيوب بالجيم
شو دخل اليوتيوب
يعني انا حاسهم بدهم انه يقبلوني بس
خايفين انه انا ما اخلصها لانه لساتني
[موسيقى]
اطلع فيه ويلا تنشوف بنبني الثقه
يلا اعطيني خمسه خمسين سنه دقيقه معك
خبرتها بطريقه ما بعرف مبروك
ابني
[موسيقى]
عدد ما كان هيقل تقريبا نصف تقريبا في
احساس صعب بالقلق المناوشات بين اعضاء
اللجنه قاربت نهايتها
الاعصاب مشدوده
التوتر يرتفع
ولا امينه خبره طويله في تهدئه المشتركين
يلا يلا قوموا كتير قاعدين
بلعب معكم لعبه كلش سريعه اوكي اذا قلت
لكم امينه قالت ترفعوا يدكم رفعوا يدكم
اذا قلت رفعوا يدكم يعني اميره ما قالت
حلو
[ضحك]
اوكي امينه تقول روحوا يدكم اليسار
نزلوا يدكم اليمين
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
امينه تقول نزلوا يدكم اليسار
رفعوا يدكم اليسار
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
احمد الخطاط
مصري
بيبقى الطريقه الوحيده ان هم اتحمموا انه
حد يدخل يتحممهم وفكر انه يعمل شاور
وفي
انه يقدر يتحمم هناك لوحده بيعتمد على
نفسه مش معتمد على حد اخر يعني بعد عمر
طويل بصير عمرك دكتور حسني 90 سنه ان شاء
الله على التسعين سنه ما بدك اولادك يحبوك
وان شاء الله قد الصحه قد العمر قد الصح
يعني يعني
[ضحك]
خليه يصطاد لانه قصته معقده
هلا الطباعه كلها بتصير عموديه
اذا بدهم يطبعوا هي افقيه بيطبعوا
وبس تخلص طباعه انت بتقعد بتنظف الاكسترا
بورت
برمي من هون واليوم من هون رح يقدر يطبع
ومش عم يطبع هو
بيوصل كانه عم يطبع هورزانتي
بوفر ماتيريال اهم شيء بوفر وقته
مرحبا اهلين سباق عزز ثقه اللجنه ليش
طيعتوك علامه اليوم وبفوت على نجوم العلوم
ورشه العمل
شخصيا انت قادر تعملها
شيكل شغل بهارفر وشاغل صفط اوكي
الكترونيكس يعني حدا عنده فكره بده ينفذها
بشتغل على اوكي
سعاده المستشار عندي سؤال اخير برضو سريع
جدا وعايز اجابه عليه بصراحه طب انت ليه
جيت للنجوم العلوم ما راحش فيه وقلت لهم
هعمل لكم
ما تقوليش عشان
[ضحك]
عايزين نعملها بالعربي لا لا هيقول لك
الامه الارم
الحقيقه ليش انت هون يعني
اوكي شكرا شكرا شكرا بالتوفيق بالتوفيق
مشكلته بالفلوس انه لبناني ارمني
[ضحك]
يلا موفق
عملتها يعني بطريقه واضحه جدا
[موسيقى]
ما بعرف يعني في هناك خمسين في المئه
يتاهل 50% لا والله نتمنى ان شاء الله
كل
امش
بس مش
صورها
هلا
كل هالقصه عربي هي اليوزر
نقطه
[موسيقى]
يعطيكم العافيه
اول وحده علمي
واصيل 40%
ثاني علامه 30% قاريين نعملها
نجوم رابع 31%
سوق واي مجتمع ممكن تخدم 30% افضل 9
علامات راح يفوتوا نجوم العلوم بالموسم
الثامن
المشاريع اللي احنا اختارها هي حتكون احسن
مشاريع كلهم ما شاء الله افكار حلوه بس
لازم ناخذ تسعه خلينا نشوف
انا عندي ثقه في تم اختيارهم وان شاء الله
بعد في النهائي نشوفوهم مشاريع المشاركين
تشرف برنامج هجوم العلوم وتشرف الشباب في
الوطن العربي
[موسيقى]
اجواء التوتر هنا تشبه اجواء التوتر في
ايام الامتحانات الجامعيه الفرق الوحيد هو
اننا نعلم ان 9 فقط سينجحون وينانونا
شهاده المشاركه في المغامره الثامنه من
نجوم العلوم وانتم فعلى من وقع اختياركم
شاركونا ارائكم عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
تويتر وسناب شات خلال هذا الفاصل الاخير
[موسيقى]
بمختبر نجوم العلوم بدنا نقي مين افضل
تسعه بين 19 كلن مناح ولكن نحن عم نبرم
مين الافضل
[موسيقى]
حاكم الله مجددا المشاهدين الكرام اينما
كنتم دقات القلوب تتسارع
والاثرينالين يحلق عاليا وعلى متنه
المشتركين جميعا فمن منهم استحق البقاء
ومن منهم سيغادر حاملا معه ذكريات لا
تنساه الحكام قالوا كلمتهم واكسل هنا
ليزفوا النتائج سيف
وخديجه تضرب التقدم
سيف وخديجه احدكم مستمر والاخر للاسف
سيضطر للمغادره هناك فقط تسعه مقاعد سيف
مبروك خديجه حظ اوفر ان شاء الله
بحترم راي الجمهور اللجنه وان شاء الله
بالتوفيق لزملائي
واحد منهم راح يضرب معانا والثاني للاسف
راح يغادرنا
سباق
ومحمد عامر
اجته
دكم ولكن للاسف تسعه مقاعد
وتقييم لجنه التحكيم مبروك لسباق
ارض لك محمد
انا على ثقه انه بمشروعي مناسب جدا وبتمنى
ان التوفيق للمشاركين ونحن حاولنا اللي
علينا ساره
بين مشتركتين هنالكم ان شاء الله كل
التوفيق وحده منكم راح تكون داخل اسوار
نجوم العلوم في موسم الثامن اما الثانيه
للاسف راح تضطر انه تغادرنا
ساره متوتره بشكل كبير
صح
مبروك
ان شاء الله شكرا
مشروع في المملكه وفي الوطن العربي ربع
المشتركين اللي راح ينضم لنا ورابع
المشتركين اللي راح يغادرنا نزار وريان
واحد منكم راح يغادرنا ونتمنى للي غادرنا
واللي يغادرونا ايضا هم يرجعون يحولون
الكره مره ثانيه السنه المقبله باذن الله
نزار
مبروك
ريان
يعني كنت متوقع بس مبروك للشباب كلهم يعني
هالسنه كلهم بيستاهلوا الان خامس المنظمين
وخامس المغادرين غسان وسميره
احدكم من البحرين والاخر من الامارات
اتمنى لكم التوفيق ان شاء الله سواء داخل
اسوار نجوم العلوم او في خارج اسوار نجوم
العلوم
غسان مبروك
[موسيقى]
حظ اوفر ان شاء الله
في شويه خيبه امل ننتقل الى سادس
المشتركين سديم وعلي الكواري
علي تلعب على ارضكم الجمهورك ولكن الحكام
ما تفرق عندهم الارض والجمهور دائما
النتائج والارقام هي من تحدد من سينضم الى
نجوم
مبروك
[تصفيق]
الحمد لله رب العالمين كان يمثل دوله قطار
خير تمثيل ولكن لا تسرع مشتركين صعبه
الصراحه صعب الاختيار ايضا على نجاه
التحكيم صعب انه يحددون احمد واحمد
تشابهتم بالاسامي لكن المصير مختلف تماما
احمد الخطاب
مبروك احمد الحسن حظ اوفر ان شاء الله
زعلان كتير انه فكره جديده
وغير كتير عن المنافسين بس شو بدي اعمل
هيك حظي
بلال وعلي اتمنى لكم ان شاء الله كل
التوفيق علي راح ارجع اقول لك نفس الكلام
اللي قلته قبل شوي حق علي تلعب على ارضكم
الجمهورك ولكن لجنه التحكيم ما تعترف الا
بالتقييم المنصف
مبروك مبروك يا علي
عبد الرحمن
نسيم
خالد تفضل
الان انتوا ثلاثه والمقعد واحد فقط
يا خالد مبروك يا عبد الرحيم
الحمد لله يعني سوينا اللي علينا
كل ما عندي ولكن عسى ان تكرهوا شيئا ويجعل
الله فيه خيرا كثيرا مشروع من قبل كان في
منافس شرسي
والحمد لله انا كتير بتشكر البرنامج على
استضافتي وانه زاد العمر لل 35 يعني فانا
يعني متقبل النتيجه مبروك الماهلين التسعه
الان سيتم تقسيمهم الى ثلاث مجموعات
بقياده ثلاث مرشدين مشتركين سابقين في
نجوم العلوم محمد وطفه ماجد دبابيدي وامين
الحواج
[موسيقى]
كثير مبسوطه اكيد لاني صرت من التسعه اللي
وصلوا للاخر وهذا هو انجاز بحد ذاته
اشكر لجنه التحكيم على الثقه اللي وضعتها
فيها وان شاء الله انا ما خيب ظنهم والثقه
اللي وضعوا فيها ان شاء الله ستكون على
ارض الواقع واصل الى مراحل متقدمه ان شاء
الله
كان في حياه ما قبل
وفيما بعد
نجوم الموسم
الثالث الف مبروك
اللي عنده شيء بسيط جدا من التحدي اللي
راح تواجهونه فنتمنى لكم ان شاء الله كل
التوفيق تسع مشتركين راح يتم تقسيمكم مثل
ما قلت على ثلاث مجموعات المجموعه الاولى
راح تكون بقياده احد خريجي نجوم العلوم
ماجد لبابيدي وراح يكون في هذه المجموعه
سيف
سباق ويازي
[موسيقى]
مجموعه ثانيه راح تكون بقياده المشتركه
السابقه في نجوم العلوم امينه الحواج وراح
يكون فيها نزار غسان وسديم
[موسيقى]
المجموعه الثالثه راح تكون بقياده المشترك
السابق في برنامج نجوم العلوم محمد وطفه
وراح تكون في المجموعه احمد الخطاب علي
السليطي وعبد الرحيم
هنالك ان شاء الله كل التوفيق شدوا الحيل
وانتم ان شاء الله قدها الكرام وصلنا
واياكم الان الى نهايه هذه الحلقه تقدرون
تتابعون برنامج نجوم العلوم وتطورات
مشاريعه عن طريق
حلقات التصفيات الجديده شكلا ومضمونا
الاسبوع المقبل في مثل هذا الوقت ان شاء
الله اما الان مثل ما على الحب التقينا
على الود دايما نلتقي تصبحون على الف خير
[موسيقى]